the jurogan experience
um that girl that amazing gymnast who
everybody's [ __ ] on
biola yeah because she just bailed on
the olympics she's like i can't take
anymore
i was just reading that she regularly
takes
um adhd medication and they
said that she can no longer take it
because in japan
you can't take this stuff she takes
ritalin
find out this is true because if that is
the case
they said that during the last olympics
uh i guess 2016 she
took this stuff and she won a bunch of
gold medals yeah
and now because she's regularly on this
right this is her medication and so
they're saying she can't because
japan japan japan is it's illegal to
take
uh whether it's adderall or ritalin i
think it's illegal to take those in
japan
so i was reading today how cultures have
their different
yeah i mean you could like buy panties
in a vending machine
but you can't take ritalin well i think
they're very sensitive to amphetamines
because
amphetamines and methamphetamines were
the reason why the kamikazes were
willing to [ __ ] fly their planes
right into boats like [ __ ] grit in
their teeth the whole way
boom that's why lexus probably does so
well because if like you mess up at the
factory you have to like walk off a
plank because of honor
they're in the honor really well i'm
just i don't know if that's true but
they don't [ __ ] i've had three lexuses
in my life they never break they're so
good they're so good i have
the best cars so this is from okay last
olympics
okay simone biles addresses leaked
medical records and adhd
misconceptions u.s gymnast superstar
simone biles was in a different kind of
spotlight tuesday
after russian hackers circulated
confidential medical reports in the
world anti-doping agency database
that showed her use of methyl
methylphendate a stimulant used to treat
adhd
biles 19 was forced to publicly address
her adhd and approval
of the use of medication after leak i
have adhd and i've taken medicine
for it since i was a kid please know i
believe in a clean sport i've always
followed the rules so we'll continue to
do so as far as play
is critical to as fair play is critical
to sport and is very important to me
so she's been on this medication for a
long time
but see if you can find that
an article that says she was not allowed
to take
this adhd medication in japan because
that's what they were saying
they were saying that during this
olympics
they told her she has to get off of it
if that's the case
that would greatly contribute to her
anxiety
and her mental problems that she's
having
imagine if you're on a medication for
last
at least five years right she's been on
since uh 2016
and then all of a sudden they tell you
can't be on it anymore and you have to
compete in the olympics yeah
and you're used to being on this
medication yeah no [ __ ]
that'll that'll cause you some strife
but this could be fishy
like they're saying they treated for
adhd
but what if this is like a drug that
makes them like super focused
well it does make you super super
focused i'm sure it does i mean that's
that's why they say pitchers can't take
it right like pitchers want to take
adderall right
yeah and they would the pitchers used to
take uh greenies
which were basically like some sort of
amphetamines amphetamines yes
so this could be a similar kind of
scandal where the russian hackers
freaking russians you know the russians
and the chinese are just like
they're beating us on the online dude
they're like they're like yago and
othello
and they're just kind of manipulating us
and having our [ __ ]
but i think about it it's like um yanis
and uh what's his name from
slovenia is like the best bat everything
is like the rest of the world has
is beating us in everything like look
now like our gymnasts are retiring
because they're sad
i don't see this is what everybody's
saying about that girl i think a thing
about that girl is her adhd medication
the deepest
i could find was people discussing that
in that so then i
outside looked up ritalin in japan turns
up that
currently the only drug used to treat
adhd that is legal in japan is called
concerta while ritalin is available in
japan is
to treat sleep disorders it's not
prescribed for adhd imagine giving you
speed for sleep disorders yeah what but
it's not illegal though right riddling
it says it's then going in it says it's
you maybe could get it it's very hard to
get and then
she could be not on it because it was
hard for her to get a t.u.e
because japan rules trump olympic rules
i think that's what's going on if you go
to i believe
it was uh chris bell's instagram page
i saw him tweet it but i think he go to
big strong fast he
he on instagram i think chris bell
covered it and he's discussing
what exactly is happening with that girl
so that's something that people needed
to
take it so many people are [ __ ] on
her online and calling her a coward it's
disgusting like
you have no idea what's going on in her
head are you supposed she's supposed to
play when she's suicidal
is she supposed to play when she's
freaking out is she supposed to do
gymnastics when
she's literally losing her mind like you
when people get off
prescription drugs like jordan peterson
was [ __ ] up for a whole year
when he was trying to get off um
benzodiazepine
i mean i don't know what it's like to
get off ritalin right but i would
imagine it's not fun
right right yeah it's withdrawal yeah
and
who knows the stuff that that girl has
done i mean she's the goat
by a lot i mean she does stuff that's
like superhuman here
simone biles adhd meds among common
drugs banned from olympics
so simone biles has revealed that she
has adhd and takes ritalin for it
uh correction it was first told adderall
in the articles looked it up it's
ritalin
very similar he says sorry she received
a
therapeutic use exemption for it in 2016
and took home four gold medals in rio
fast forward to tokyo 2020 and ritalin
and adderall
is 100 illegal in japan under all
circumstances including therapeutic use
it is unfair unfortunate because i'm
sure we'd love to see her compete but it
makes sense
that she couldn't focus that does make
sense
see now why are we not hearing this why
am i getting this only from chris bell
who by the way made an incredible
documentary bigger stronger faster
which is a documentary on steroids and
then another documentary prescription
thugs which about prescription
medication
great he does great [ __ ] so i guess at
this point it's either that's true or
what jaime
pulled up before is true like we're not
sure because jamie's saying the article
he wrote is that it's not illegal
i bet it might be illegal for
competition right it might be illegal as
a therapeutic use exemption you might
not be able to get one of those
right whatever chris is saying but it's
uh
it's a complicated story it's not i mean
this girl's she won four gold medals in
rio what do you
she's not a chicken she's the best of
all time by by all people's accounts
aren't they changing rules because she
can do [ __ ] that other people can't do
yeah
she's right yeah she like flies through
the air it's incredible
there was a video that was uh describing
how
they're literally like altering the
rules to make what she does
less impressive right or less uh scores
less whatever
right i don't follow gymnastics yeah
yeah i mean most people don't until the
olympics i mean right that's the thing
about olympic sports like
these people that must be a weird come
down like you know
the whole world's watching then you got
to go back to working at uh panera bread
that's weird yeah you're just a swimmer
or like a shot put guy
uh-huh you win a gold and then you're
just back to
handing out buzzers greg how much money
do you make for the shop but i don't
think they make anything
for the olympics you win the olympics
and then then what
you just teach shot put people that also
can't make money
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience